اهلا بكم من جديد تشهد فرنسا اليوم الموجه
الثامنه من التحرك الاحتجاجي ضد خطه
الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما سيكون
يوما للاضراب والتظاهر حيث يشمل الاضراب
عددا واسعا من القطاعات اهمها الطاقه
والمواصلات الداخليه والنقل هيئه الطيران
المدني اعلنت انها طلبت الغاء 20% من
الرحلات الجويه من مطار اورلي بما يخص
التظاهرات الموكب الباريسي سيتحرك بعد ظهر
اليوم
وسيتزامن مع دراسه لجنتين من مجلس النواب
والشيوخ لمشروع قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
من اجل التوصل الى نص متوافق عليه من
الطرفين اذ صوت مجلس الشيوخ السبت الماضي
لصالح المشروع بينما لا يزال الامر عالقا
في مجلس النواب الذي لم يتمكن من التصويت
عليه بعد
وتفقد مدينه النور بريقها بعد تراكم
القمامه على ارصفه باريس بسبب استمرار
اضراب عمال الصرف الصحي وجامعي القمامه
تنظفي الشوارع الذي يدخل يومه التاسع
احتجاجا على قانون المعاشات التقاعديه
الذي يسعى الرئيس الفرنسي اما نويل ماكرون
تطبيقه في فرنسا وذكرت وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه وكاله الفرنسيه في تقريرها ان
القذاره الزاحفه في معظم شوارع باريس
الرئيسيه ورائحه الطعام المتعفن التي
تتسرب من بعض اكياس القمامه وصناديق
القمامه الممتلئه عن اخرها بالقمامه هي
العلامه الاكثر وضوحا على الغضب واسع
النطاق بشان مشروع قانوني رفعي سنه تقاعد
الفرنسي لمده عامين ومظاهر الاضراب تلك لم
ينجو منها كما اوضحت الوكاله الفرنسيه سوى
القصر الذي يضم مجلس الشيوخ ويقع على بعد
خطوات من قصر الاليزي حيث المقر الرئيسي
ولذيذ تم تنظيف شوارعهما من القمامه
وينضم الينا من باريس مراسل العربيه فادي
الدهوك اهلا بك معنا فادي يعني اضراب عمال
النظافه يتواصل وكذلك الاحتجاجات ماذا في
تفاصيل
حل وسط
للقضيتين والاحتجاجين
صباح الخير راويه نحن الان في الايام
الاخيره من اجل اقرار او رفض مشروع رفع سن
التقاعد الى 64 عاما قبل نصف ساعه من الان
بدا اجتماع لجنتين من
مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي وايضا مجلس النواب
لجنه مشتركه ستناقش نصا مشتركا بين
المجلسين لرفعه لاحقا الى التصويت لمجلس
الشيوخ يوم غد ومن ثم الى مجلس النواب
مجلس الشيوخ يبدو انه اكثر قربا للتصويت
عليه مجددا لنص المشروع الجديد لكن مجلس
النواب الامور ليست محسومه بعد هناك
معارضه شديده لنص هذا القانون وقد يلجا
الرئيس ماكرون والحكومه الى استخدام
الماده الدستوريه رقم
49,3 من اجل اقراره بالقوه من دون المرور
عبر مرحله التصويت اليوم هي الموجه
الثامنه كما ذكرتي من الاحتجاجات والاضراب
الاضرابات متواصله في عدد كبير من القط
خصوصا في قطاع النقل والطيران هناك 20% من
الرحلات الغيت اليوم من مطار اورلي ايضا
في مجال الطاقه في قطاع الطاقه هناك
اضرابات مستمره في مصافي النفط وايضا في
المحطات الاربعه التي تستورد الغاز
الموسال الى فرنسا كذلك هناك اضرابات في
قطاع التعليم والصحه وقطاعات اخرى كثيره
ايضا الابرز المشهد الابرز هو مشهد
القمامه في العاصمه باريس المنتشره منذ
تسعه ايام لا لم تزل
منتشره في كل الشوارع وهي تتكدس يوما بعد
يوم على كل جنبات الطرق يمكن رؤيتها نحن
هنا في الدائره الباريسيه الثامنه صناديق
القمامه كما ترون ما زالت منتشره والعمال
الذين
بداوا هذا الاضراب اعلنوا انه تمديده حتى
يوم الاثنين المقبل حتى مطلع الاسبوع
المقبل حتى الان حجم هذه القمامه المنتشره
في الشوارع تجاوز الاف طن في العاصمه
وحدها لكن ايضا هناك
اطنان منتشره في عدد كبير من المدن
الفرنسيه وهذا المشهد
بدا يقلق عدد كبير من الجهات خصوصا
الحكوميه لان التظاهره اليوم قد يتمكن
المتظاهرون من استخدام هذه القمامه وتكون
اداه في ايديهم لاشعالها في الشوارع لذلك
شرطه باريس قياده شرطه باريس وايضا وزير
الداخليه طالبا يوم امس من عمده مدينه
باريس ان تتحرك على الفور لتزيل هذه
القمامه على الاقل من مسار التظاهره كي لا
يتمكن المتظاهرون من الاستفاده منها للقاء
المقذوفات باتجاه عناصر الشرطه او حتى
اشعال النار فيها خلال مسيرهم في هذا
الموكب الباريسي
عربيه